in the opening scene we see a man named
Thomas Richardson who is anxiously
reading a letter from his sister while
traveling on a train the letter reveals
that his sister Jennifer has been
abducted and is being held for ransom by
a cult a flashback shows that Thomas
returned home after a long Gap only to
discover his sister missing and his
father in a deteriorated State the
family lawyer informed Thomas of
Jennifer's whereabouts a place called
Welsh Island he also instructed Thomas
to enter the cult posing as a convert
and not to pay the ransom until they
released his sister in the present
Thomas gets off the train and proceeds
to board a boat to the island while
waiting in line he notices that the
ticket has a distinctive red mark unlike
the others in a clever move he pretends
to help a fellow passenger and swaps
tickets this enables Thomas to
successfully board the boat while the
man with the red marked ticket receives
a cross symbol on his luggage on their
way a sudden storm hits causing a goat
on the boat to fall into the passenger
compartment Thomas picks it up but
another passenger snatches it from him
and throws it into the water try not to
laugh citing it as a sacrifice demanded
by their goddess in the morning the
group reaches the Coast and they
continue the rest of their Journey on
foot eventually arriving at a quaint
old-fashioned Village there all of them
are examined and interrogated one after
another before being led to their
respective Cottages that evening Thomas
walks out of his Cottage to explore the
village during his walk he Witnesses
villagers bringing an unconscious man
Thomas is curious to know what's going
on but he opts not to intervene after
this he goes to the nearby Church where
the Cults leader Malcolm how is
delivering a speech about the island
Malcolm recounts how he and two other
friends Frank and Quinn escaped England
due to religious persecution and ended
up here later the unconscious man from
earlier is subjected to a brutal beating
by Malcolm Franken Quinn it turns out he
is the same man with whom Thomas swapped
his ticket the trio believe that the man
is Jennifer's father who has come to
rescue his daughter they demand for the
ransom but the man is clueless about the
situation frustrated they slid his
throat and brutally kill him despite
this Malcolm still believes that there's
an intruder in their Village that same
night Thomas sneaks out from his Cottage
and secretly wanders around the village
in search of his sister during this he
Witnesses a husband cutting his wife's
arm to offer her blood as a sacrifice
next he Peaks into Malcolm's place and
sees the cult leader descending through
a secret trap door in the floor shortly
after he comes across Frank's son Jeremy
and Quinn's daughter theen who are
sneaking home after sharing some
intimate moments together following all
of this Thomas returns to his Cottage
and while unlocking the door he
inadvertently cuts his hand as he enters
his blood on the floor starts moving
inexplicably toward the gaps in the
wooden floorboards the next morning a
knock on Thomas's door Rouses him from
sleep answering the door he finds Jeremy
who has come to summon him to go to the
assigned work in the midst of work
Jeremy asks Thomas about the reason why
he was out last night to which the
latter claims that he was just having a
cigarette a short while later the boy
leads Thomas to a seashore and shows him
a wrecked boat Jeremy explains that a
spy was caught trying to flee the island
but he drowned into the sea he believes
that their goddess killed the spy and
saved their cult following this Thomas
shows him a picture of his missing
sister and inquires about her
whereabouts this puts the boy at Great
unease so he tries to walk away however
Thomas forces him to reveal everything
he knows Jeremy then discloses that
Jennifer was abducted for ransom because
the cult doesn't have enough crops to
feed its members they're also lacking
the necessary resources to pay for the
continuous animal sacrifices needed to
maintain the Island's fertility after
hearing this Thomas asks the boy to help
him in his mission and in exchange he'll
keep Jeremy's Affair a secret on the
other hand Fen is talking to her friend
Andrea who happens to be Thomas's
daughter Fen confesses that she might be
pregnant with Jeremy's baby however she
fears that they might be caught because
premarital intercourse is considered to
be a sin in their Cults thankfully
Andrea doesn't judge her and is ready to
support her in this matter later that
day Malcolm summons all the newly
arrived cult members to the church he
announces about a breach of a village
rule prohibition against leaving one's
room after the night Bell in order to
find out the culprit he orders everyone
to kneel down and recite the cult's
prayer the true adherence take turns
reciting it which makes Thomas nervous
shortly after Malcolm approaches the man
next to Thomas and instructs him to
continue the prayer the man remains
silent for a moment before revealing
himself as an undercover English spy he
swiftly draws his knife to attack
Malcolm but Thomas intervenes saving the
cult leader and injuring himself in the
process after this the guards stab their
Spears through the spy's body killing
him on the spot in the aftermath Thomas
is rushed to a medical facility where
Andrea helps him intending to his wound
as she applies a bandage to his injury
Thomas asks her if she resents her
father for making her part of this cult
but Andrea has no answer at night
Malcolm parades Jennifer through the
village issuing threats to kill her if
her co-conspirator doesn't come forward
Thomas watches this from his window but
he is unable to gather enough courage to
confront the cult leader meanwhile
Malcolm imposes a limited time frame for
the Intruder to reveal themselves before
leaving the following morning Jennifer
is restrained in Chains while children
poke her for fun not long after Andrea
comes to her with some food and a
blanket she orders the kids to leave and
Promises Jennifer that she'll try her
best not to let anyone harm her
meanwhile Fen goes to the back bathroom
to check if she's really pregnant
unbeknownst to her her father Quinn is
keeping an eye on her through a door
hole he senses something am Miss but
chooses to keep it to himself for the
time being later on Thomas notices that
his sister is being taken somewhere else
he then tells Jeremy to be ready because
he'll be executing his plan tonight on
that night Malcolm hosts a village-wide
feast allowing everyone to eat this
Festival turns out to be Malcolm's plan
to distract everyone so that he can
search their home homes shortly after
Thomas exits his Cottage only to stumble
upon Andrea she asks him for a dance but
he turns her down because he's a
tormented badass and he has to carry out
his rescue plan following this Thomas
meets Jeremy behind Malcolm's house he
breaks into the house and enters the
secret basement which leads to a dark
tunnel in the meantime Malcolm Quinn and
Frank search Thomas's quarters where
they find a floor plan of their house
this discovery confirms their suspicion
that Thomas is the Intruder prompting
the three of them to hurry to Malcolm's
Place Frank arrives first and notices
his son on watch Duty he hurriedly sends
his son away avoiding any potential
suspicions surrounding the boy's
involvement moments later Quinn enters
the tunnel while Malcolm arms himself
with a shotgun and moves towards the
other exit inside the tunnel Thomas
senses that he's being trailed so he
dives into a sewer filled with blood and
sludge in order to hide himself a short
while later a creepy old woman emerges
from the blood and charges towards
Thomas freaking him out she gives this
weird ecstatic baby shriek thing it's
[__] in a state of panic he crawls
away and soon ends up inside a dark
Beach cave when he turns back the woman
mysteriously disappears Thomas then uses
a lighter as a makeshift torch to look
around only to discover the Cave's walls
covered in markings depicting a deity
outside Malcolm visits a barn where the
same old woman is imprisoned in tree
roots she turns out out to be the
Island's deity whom the cult members all
worship Malcolm reprimands her for
showing herself to Thomas and then
proceeds to feed her with his blood as
the woman drinks the blood the
vegetation that binds her begins to
bloom the following morning Andrea finds
Thomas in the cave and provides him with
a set of clothes to change into during
this she notices numerous bruises on his
back prompting her to question it Thomas
reveals that he was a Christian
Missionary who once went to China to
ruce Christianity there however he was
caught and persecuted by the locals as a
punishment they burned his back this
experience led to his loss of faith in
God as he received no help during his
time of need following this conversation
Andrea leads him into the middle of a
wheat field and shows him a place where
he can hide back in the village Theon
confides in Jeremy about pregnancy which
makes him happy he then tells her that
he is leaving the village forever with
his father and expresses his wish to
take her along long fien is happy to
start her new life and degrees to
accompany him after this Jeremy goes to
prepare while she packs her belongings
moments later Quinn walks in and demands
an explanation Fen reveals about the
baby in her B and her decision to keep
it this infuriates her father and
believing it to be a sin he mutilates
her in a forced abortion which results
in her death a short while later Jeremy
returns only to discover his Lover's
lifeless body drenched in blood consumed
by grief he engages in a physical
altercation with Quinn seeking
retribution however Quinn manages to
make his way out of the house screaming
for help he catches everyone's attention
and manipulates the situation by Framing
the boy for fen's death overwhelmed and
desperate Jeremy flees to the wheat
fields and begs Andrea's help to prove
his innocence unfortunately it's too
late as the guards apprehend both Thomas
and Jeremy and return them to the
village in the next scene Quinn prepares
for a public execution by placing the
boy in a torturing device as a cruel
form of punishment he inserts a metal
drill hollowing out the back of Jeremy's
head a few moments later Malcolm and
Frank arrive at the scene and confront
Quinn for his actions however Quinn
instead calls Malcolm a false prophet
and addresses him as a weak person he
also demands that he prove himself by
executing Thomas but before this Frank
pulls out his gun and vows to end
everything by killing the deity Thomas
uses this distraction to fight the
guards and frees himself from captivity
he then pursues Frank to the barn where
the deity is held as soon as Frank
enters the barn he's shot by the deity's
masked caretaker grinder grinder in his
last breath Frank asks Thomas to burn
the barn down as grinder walks out
Thomas hides himself and enters the barn
through a secret passage shortly after
Quinn and Malcolm arrive at the scene to
make matters worse Quinn decides to
shoot grinder but Malcolm stops him in a
fit of rage Quinn shoots the cult leader
which causes him to fall into the tunnel
inside the barn Thomas Witnesses grinder
extracting blood from a corpse and
feeding it to the deity when grinder
leaves the barn for a while Thomas
searches around and finds some sacks one
of which contains Jennifer he hurriedly
tears it open and takes his sister out
the siblings share an emotional hug and
Thomas promises to take her back home
but right then grinder a appears and
smacks Thomas's head from behind before
taking Jennifer away sometime later
Thomas regains his Consciousness and
finds himself restrained on a meat
grinding table with hooks embedded in
his hands and legs he is slowly pulled
towards the sharp spikes and eventually
has his fingers chopped off but before
the machine can grind the rest of his
body Thomas somehow manages to break
free and starts fighting grinder he
eventually overpowers the caretaker and
kills him using the same grinding
machine grinder evolved into grinded
following this Thomas stands in front of
the deity who pleads with him to set her
free however he instead grabs a lantern
and sets the entire barn on fire which
quickly spreads throughout the village
meanwhile Quinn who has chained both
Andrea and Jennifer shares his plan to
repeatedly impregnate them and use their
offspring as blood sacrifices okay Quinn
you're drunk time to go home just then
Thomas shows up and starts fighting him
amidst this commotion the two girls
manag to retrieve Quinn's gun and use it
to free themselves from chains after
this the three of them team up to
strangle Quinn to death but sadly Thomas
sustains heavy stab wounds in the
process despite this he escorts the
girls to the boats so that they can flee
the island with the rest of the
villagers on the way Thomas collapses to
the ground and he seems to be dying due
to his injuries realizing that he won't
make it he instructs them to get going
bidding them goodbye as Thomas bleeds
onto the ground the vegetation around
him grows and infuses within his body
his eyes then turned to the same shape
and color as the deities signifying his
rebirth as the new guardian of the
island subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching